sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren in den
vergangenen neun Jahren durfte ich schon
so einige
bereinigungssitzungen des
Haushaltsausschusses erleben
die Sitzung neulich war mit Abstand die
längste 18 eineinhalb Stunden haben wir
getagt wir alle kennen das Sprichwort
was lange währt wird endlich gut
wer aber glaubt dass dieser Satz auch
hier gilt den muss ich leider
enttäuschen warum
ich habe selten erlebt dass selbst so
viele Ministerinnen und Minister im
Haushaltsausschuss ganz unverblümt
bekennen dass sie mit ihrem Etat nicht
zufrieden sind bei uns in der letzten
Legislatur war das immer nur einer
wir Befund hinten uns in der größten
Krise dieses Landes wir spüren die
Herausforderungen für fast jeden für uns
aber auch für den Bundeshaushalt waren
nie so groß und ins solcher Situation
hat eine Regierungskoalition im Kern
zwei Möglichkeiten entweder
man nimmt neue Schulden auf oder man
bringt die Kraft auf
Ausgaben zu priorisieren und darüber den
Haushalt zumindest ein Stück weit zu
konsolidieren diese Chance aber hat die
Ampel leider verpasst sie hat die
maximal mögliche Nettokreditaufnahme von
45,6 Milliarden voll ausgereizt ihr
Haushalt ist ein rot-grün-gelbes wünscht
dir was wo man doch gerade in so einer
Situation dringend Prioritäten setzen
muss und zwar genau auf die Bereiche in
denen der Bedarf ganz offenkundig
besonders dringend besteht und
und das das sind ganz aktuell das
Auswärtige Amt das BMZ und das
Verteidigungsministerium
der Regierungsentwurf des
Finanzministers hingegen war gerade für
AA und BMZ aber das sind wir uns als
Union einig auch für das BMVg absolut
unzureichend
wir als Opposition aber auch die
Haushälter der Koalition haben in den
Beratungen regelmäßig erklärt dass in
den Beratungen genau an diesen Stellen
massiv nachgebessert werden muss mit
diesem Regierungsentwurf hat der BMF das
Parlament quasi gezwungen in die Presse
zu springen ich nehme mal nur ein
Beispiel aus dem Auswärtigen Amt die
humanitäre Hilfe im Regierungsentwurf
von zweieinhalb Milliarden auf zwei
Milliarden gekürzt und dieses unzählige
Spiel wurde von der Regierung wieder
gespielt dass sie genau an diesen
Stellen gekürzt hat wovon von vornherein
völlig klar ist dass diese Kürzungen vom
Parlament nicht unwidersprochen bleiben
können
dieses dieses Spiel das das ist nicht
nur unredlich das ist auch unseriös und
ich finde auch absolut überflüssig und
ein solches Gebaren lässt uns auch im
Ausland schlecht aussehen und gerade in
Zeiten der Krise verunsichert es auch
unsere Partner das muss wirklich nicht
sein immerhin
immerhin ist es dann doch gelungen im
Etat des Auswärtigen Amt massiv
nachzubessern in der Bereinigung kamen
eine dringend benötigte Milliarde und
top der größte Teil dessen fließt
natürlich in die humanitäre Hilfe der
Bedarf dort ist leider nach wie vor
enorm und für uns als Union war vor
diesem Hintergrund klar dass wir die
Stärkung der humanitären Hilfe an dieser
Stelle mittragen
die Ukraine
ist leider nicht der einzige Krisenherd
auf der Welt seit wenigen Wochen gehen
die Menschen im Iran auf die Straße
protestieren gegen das unmenschliche
eiertolerische die Lage im Iran ist
dramatisch
Sicherheitskräfte gehen mit brutaler
Gewalt gegen die Proteste vor hunderte
wurden bereits getötet tausende
festgenommen wir dürfen nicht schweigen
wenn friedliche Demonstranten als Feinde
Gottes zum Tode verurteilt werden
ihre ersten Äußerungen hierzu sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin all das habe
nichts mit Religion zu tun waren gelinde
gesagt schon etwas blauäugig deshalb
freue ich mich aber umso mehr dass sie
hier mittlerweile kein Blatt mehr vor
den Mund nehmen leider hat die Ampel
unseren Antrag die
demonstrationsbewegung im Iran zu
unterstützen nicht mitgetragen ein
weiterer Punkt der hier im Inland aber
auch bei unseren europäischen Partnern
für massive Irritationen gesorgt hat das
ist das Verhalten unseres Bundeskanzlers
gegenüber China
auffällig ist vor allem die
unterschiedliche Positionierung von
Kanzler und Außenministerin der Auftritt
des Bundeskanzlers in China war sogar so
verstörend dass sie sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerin es für nötig hielten ihn zu
maßregeln sehr geehrte Frau bärburg ich
bin sicher nicht mit jeder Frage ihre
Einführung einverstanden aber was Sie
von unserem Kanzler unterscheidet sie
vertreten die Interessen unseres Landes
mit einem klaren außenpolitischen
Kompass da wo der kanzlerführung nur
vollmundig versprochen hat
ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen Frau
Ministerin beim Auswärtigen Amt und bei
meinen geschätzten Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mitberichterstattern für die
angenehme und konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
als nächstes hält das Wort die Kollegen
ja Mila Schäfer Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und euch Jamila Schäfer ist
Berichterstatterin ihrer Fraktion für
diesen Einzelplan herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zwei Milliarden mehr gegen autokarten 2
Milliarden mehr gegen eine globale
Ernährungskrise das hat dieses Parlament
das haben wir gemeinsam im
Haushaltsausschuss für das Auswärtige
Amt und das Entwicklungsministerium
erreicht vielen Dank dafür insbesondere
an meine mitberichterstatterinnen Wiebke
Papenburg und Otto Fricke und natürlich
auch eines wenn Christian Kindler und
Dennis Rode damit hat wertegeleitete
Außenpolitik ein größeres Budget als je
zuvor und das ist angesichts der vielen
globalen Herausforderungen dieser Tage
genau richtig dieses Parlament zeigt mit
dem vorliegenden Haushalt dass es
schnell und wirksam auf die Forderungen
und Nöte in der Ukraine im Iran und in
anderen Krisen Regionen der Welt
reagiert
wir haben diesen Haushalt zu einem
schlagkräftigen Instrument einer aktiven
Außenpolitik gemacht und dass das Geld
hier wirklich gut investiert ist das
zeigt die großartige Arbeit unserer
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock
wir geben 82 Millionen zusätzlich für
eine vorausschauende zivile
Krisenprävention aus damit unterstützen
wir zum Beispiel die Dokumentation
russischer Kriegsverbrechen und wirken
ds-informationen entgegen auch das
Budget für die humanitäre Hilfe war nie
höher mit den zusätzlichen 7008
Millionen aus dem Haushaltsverfahren
stehen 2023 insgesamt 2,7 Milliarden
Euro zur Verfügung das ist Geld was die
Ukraine dringend braucht aber was eben
auch dazu beiträgt dass sich das Elend
dieses Krieges nicht noch in andere
Weltregionen weiter ausbreitet wir gehen
damit zum Beispiel auch gegen
Lebensmittelknappheit vor z.B am Horn
von Afrika mit 86 Millionen Euro mehr
für die auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik halten wir die Kultur
Milliarde ein
damit helfen wir zum Beispiel mit dem
Dad gemeinsam verfolgten Studierenden
aus der Ukraine oder aus Russland und
wir fördern mit den politischen
Stiftungen gemeinsam den Ausbau
russischer exilstrukturen in den
Nachbarländern und Stärken Programme zum
Schutz von kritischen Journalistinnen
und Journalisten insbesondere auch im
Iran denn sie sorgen dafür dass die Welt
die Verbrechen des mularegimes und die
mutigen Proteste im Iran mitbekommt sie
sehen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Kultur Milliarde rettet Leben und sie
verteidigt unsere Demokratie
was eigentlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit sein sollte
nämlich dass Menschen auf dem Mittelmeer
aus Seenot gerettet werden vor dem
Ertrinken unterstützen wir nun auch im
Bundeshaushalt mit 8 Millionen Euro über
vier Jahre hinweg unterstützen wir einen
breitgetragenen Verein von
seenotrettungsorganisationen das Sterben
auf dem Mittelmeer ist nach dem Krieg in
der Ukraine die zweitgrößte humanitäre
Katastrophe in Europa und wir dürfen sie
nicht einfach so hinnehmen und ja das
sollte auch in ihrem christlichen
Menschenbild eigentlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit sein und ich
möchte noch mal ganz klar sagen wer das
in den Dreck zieht der sollte sich
wirklich fragen ob sein Verständnis von
Menschenrechten wirklich universell und
christlich ist denn Werte verteidigt man
doch am besten wenn man sie selbst
vorlebt
ich möchte zum Schluss noch auf eines
hinweisen die außenpolitischen
Herausforderungen die werden in den
kommenden Jahren voraussichtlich nicht
kleiner wir werden auch weiterhin eine
handlungsfähige und aktive Außenpolitik
brauchen und ich hoffe dass das bei den
weiteren Planungen der Bundesregierung
zu dem Bundeshaushalt im nächsten Jahr
und auch den folgenden Haushalten
abgebildet sein wird die Unterstützung
dieses Parlaments haben sie vielen Dank
Jamila Schäfer war das sie ist jetzt dem
bundesfinanzierungsgremium vor das
Bundesministerium der Finanzen muss die
sind Gremium
unterrichten über alle Fragen des
schuldenwesen des Bundes und das
bedeutet natürlich dass das für den
Bundeshaushalt auch höchste relevant ist
Michael Essen Bilder ist schon am Pult
für die afd-fraktion herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im Saal
und bei Youtube 2023 darf sich das
Auswärtige Amt über 7,5 Milliarden Euro
zum Ausgeben freuen die Ampel lässt es
also ordentlich krachen und alle anderen
hier im Haus klatschen Beifall nur wir
sagen das ist zu viel
es ist so viel und das vor allem auch im
Hinblick auf die spannende Frage was
passiert eigentlich mit dem Geld wo
fließt das hin und macht es was es soll
im Koalitionsvertrag haben sich die
ampelparteien auf eine
wirkungsorientierte Haushaltspolitik
verständigt davon haben wir aber recht
wenig gesehen wenn der Haushaltstitel
irgendwie gut klingt und da was von
Klima oder Nachhaltigkeit drinsteht dann
fliegen die Milliarden nur so aus dem
Fenster ab ins Ausland machen wir es mal
konkret wir haben es in den Beratungen
auch schon angesprochen es gibt das
sogenannte Bundesamt für auswärtige
Angelegenheiten das ist eine schicke
neue Behörde in des Auswärtigen Amtes im
schönen Brandenburg an der Havel und
dort arbeiten jede Menge motivierte
Sachbearbeiter wir konnten uns das
gemeinsam mit der Ministerin mal ansehen
und das war wirklich sehr interessant
einer der Abteilungsleiter hat uns
erklärt dass in seiner Abteilung in
diesem Jahr ca 1.900 Projekte von 62
Mitarbeitern bearbeitet werden Projekte
in 130 Ländern der Welt mit einem
Gegenwert von 2 Milliarden Euro
erinnern wir das jetzt mal durch dann
verantwortet jede einzelne
Sachbearbeiter pro Jahr weltweit
Projekte im Gesamtwert von 32,3
Millionen Euro ein Mitarbeiter 32
Millionen Euro da haben wir natürlich
gefragt wie kann ein einzelner
Sachbearbeiter bei so einer großen Summe
prüfen und nachvollziehen ob das Geld
auch wirklich ankommt und etwas bewirkt
die Antwort lautete das wäre wäre
kursorisch geprüft gucken wir in den
Duden was das heißt kusorisch
fortlaufend von einem zum anderen rasch
fortschreitend nicht auf Einzelheiten
eingehend vereinfacht gesagt wenn sie
Gelder für ein Projekt beantragen wird
kurz darüber geguckt abgestempelt das
Geld wird überwiesen hinterher noch ein
kurzer Bericht geschrieben war alles
super schön fertig ab zu den Akten die
Ministerin hat nach unserer Kritik an
diesem Prozedere ausgeführt dass die
Projekte vom Auswärtigen Amt vorgeprüft
werden vor allem aber die Projektpartner
allerdings hat Frau Bär Bock auch gesagt
Zitat wir kontrollieren nicht jede
einzelne Rechnung wir kontrollieren
nicht jeden einzeln das können wir ja
gar nicht Zitat sehen Sie und genau da
liegt der Hase im Pfeffer denn es ist
mitnichten so dass sie nicht jeden
einzelnen Bau kontrollieren können
sondern sie wollen es einfach nicht
die förderabteilung des auswendigen
Amtes sind darauf ausgerichtet gilt
auszugeben wäre es ihnen wichtig Frau
Ministerin wo auch immer Sie gerade sind
würden sie die Abteilung umstrukturieren
sie würden ohne Kontrolle kein Geld
ausgeben aber sie tun genau das
Gegenteil und in welche Länder wird das
Geld dann überhaupt überwiesen
beispielsweise haben sie vorgestern
weitere 33 Millionen Euro für die
Republik Moldau zugesagt überwiegend im
Bereich Energiesicherheit ein Blick in
den Korruptionsindex von Transfer
international zeigt für dieses Land kein
gutes Bild die Republik Moldau landet
dort auf Platz 105 gleich auf mit Panama
und liegt damit in Sachen Korruption
weltweit vorne immerhin aber noch leicht
hinter der Ukraine ich denke Frau
Hagedorn viele Menschen können den
Ansatz der Regierung durchaus
nachvollziehen dem Land zu helfen das
Land ist vom Krieg stark betroffen aber
gerade im Hinblick auf die Korruption
ist es ihnen doch ein besonderes
Anliegen sein hier eine ordentliche
Kontrolle durchzuführen
[Applaus]
Kontrolle damit die Gelder wirklich
etwas bewirken und das tun sie halt
gerade nicht bloß weil wir das hier
sagen vertrauen ist gut Kontrolle ist
besser und falls Sie jetzt jemand sagt
ja Mensch dafür haben wir doch dem
Bundesrechnungshof das ist ein Irrtum
der kontrolliert nämlich keine Projekte
die Kapazitäten dazu hat er gar nicht
wie genau also mit dem Geld das
Steuerzahlers umgegangen wird ist damit
eine Weichenstellung die Sie vornehmen
müssen Frau Ministerin doch sie und die
Haus kontrollieren ja nicht jede
einzelne Rechnung und nicht jeden
einzelnen aber wissen Sie wer das tun
muss die Steuerzahler in Deutschland die
dieses Geld erwirtschaften dass sie
großzügig verteilen die Bürger müssen
bei jedem Euro genau hinsehen denn
normale Menschen können das Geld nur
einmal ausgeben die Bürger müssen bei
jedem Euro eine Rechnung aufbewahren für
ihre Steuererklärung zum Beispiel wenn
sie in Deutschland einen Betrieb führen
dann müssen sie das sogar für zehn Jahre
tun und wenn dann eines schönen Tages
die Steuerprüfung kommt und die kommt zu
sicher wie das Amen in der Kirche dann
werden sich die Steuerprüfer auch jeden
einzelnen Euro und jeden einzelnen
Bonbon und jede einzelne Rechnung genau
ansehen und es Gnade ihnen Gott wenn
dann irgendwas damit nicht stimmt wenn
Sie also so leichthin darüber sprechen
dass sie das alles gar nicht so genau
prüfen können dann lehnen sie für sich
und Ihr Haus damit einen Standard ab der
für Millionen Deutsche eine Pflicht ist
[Applaus]
und Frau Ministerin da hilft auch kein
Kopfschütteln das ist Nummer ein Fakt
und abseits von unterschiedlichen
außenpolitischen Vorstellungen fordern
wir hier von ihnen wirklich mehr
Kontrolle das sind sie den Steuerzahlern
in diesem Land mehr als schuldig
[Applaus]
vielen Dank
soweit Michael Espen adilla auf ihn
folgt nun die Berichterstatterin für die
SPD-Fraktion das ist Wiebke papenburg
ist in genau 7 Sekunden vorbei deshalb
frage ich ist noch ein Mitglied her
und das sehen sie gerade nicht aber wir
sehen hier doch noch mindestens eine
sogar zwei Abgeordnete sportliche
Einlagen einlegen die Rennen nämlich
noch mal schnell in die West Lobby ach
jetzt sehen sie es auch wunderbar um
ihre Stimme abzugeben für den Einzelplan
04 das Bundeskanzleramt
noch eine auf dann wird es bunt ich
frage noch einmal ist noch ein Mitglied
des Hauses Anwesen dass seine Stimme
noch nicht abgegeben wird
hier ist sie abgenommen worden ist man
sozusagen
wir warten noch kurz auf die Kollegin
Schäfer die müssen einschmeißen
so ein bisschen körperliche Ertüchtigung
ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlechte
denn auch der Bundestag möchte Energie
sparen und das bedeutet dass es sehr
viel kühler ist als sonst hier im Winter
maximal 19 20 Grad sind es im Plenarsaal
darauf hat man sich im Ältestenrat
geeinigt um eben auch nicht zu viel
Energie hier auszugeben das war eine
Initiative der
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Bars und
jetzt kommt aber Wiebke parken Bruck für
die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren unsere
Außenpolitik hat angesichts der
weltweiten kriegen weltweiten Krisen
besondere Bedeutung erlangt deshalb ist
es konsequent und richtig dass wir im
Parlament den Etat des Auswärtigen Amtes
noch einmal mit einer Milliarde Euro im
Vergleich zum Regierungsentwurf stärken
das ist ein deutliches Signal was von
uns als Regierungskoalition hier im
Parlament ausgeht
es zeigt wie wichtig uns unsere deutsche
Außenpolitik ist zusammen stark sein
bedeutet dass wir gemeinsam etwas
bewegen können wenn es darauf ankommt
zum Beispiel bei der humanitären Hilfe
und in der internationalen Kultur und
Bildungspolitik dafür gilt mein Dank
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
Haushaltsausschuss sowie den
Fachpolitikern
ich möchte zuerst auf die auswärtige
Kultur- und Bildungspolitik zu sprechen
kommen die uns bei den parlamentarischen
Beratungen besonders wichtig war sie ist
ein wichtiges Fundament wenn es darum
geht Brücken zu bauen und das Vertrauen
in die Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu
stärken gerade auch in schwierigen
Zeiten sie hilft ein positives Bild
Deutschlands im Ausland zu vermitteln
und sie spielt eine wichtige Rolle wenn
es darum geht dem wachsenden
Fachkräftebedarf bei uns zu begegnen es
ist deshalb eine gute Nachricht dass wir
erneut insgesamt eine Milliarde Euro für
unsere internationale Kultur und
Bildungspolitik zur Verfügung stellen
wenn wir mal beim Thema Fachkräfte
bleiben
ob im Handwerk im Gesundheitswesen oder
in der Metallverarbeitung die Mehrzahl
der Betriebe in meinem Wahlkreis und das
meiste sind kleine und mittelständische
Unternehmen sucht händeringend nach
Auszubildenden und gut ausgebildeten
Arbeitskräften das ist überall in
Deutschland der Fall
das Bundesarbeitsministerium schätzt
dass jedes Jahr 400.000 Fachkräfte
einwandern müssten damit wir unseren
Bedarf an Fachkräften decken könnten
weil so viele Auszubildende und
Fachkräfte fehlen müssen viele Betriebe
Aufträge ablehnen und manche geben ganz
auf oder schließen weil sie keinen
Nachfolger finden
wir müssen deshalb alles daran setzen
mehr qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte zu uns
zu holen und das tun wir auch
und das Arbeitsminister Hubertus Heil
hat vor vier Wochen Eckpunkte für ein
neues Zuwanderungsgesetz vorgestellt
dabei geht es auch darum dass es
Bewerberinnen und Bewerbern aus Ländern
außerhalb der Europäischen Union
einfacher haben sollen wenn Sie zu uns
kommen wollen
auch auf die Frage wie wir mehr
Fachkräfte gewinnen gibt es viele
Antworten und es ist wie so oft komplex
mehr Zuzug allein wird unseren
Fachkräftebedarf nicht decken die
Zuwanderung qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte
vor allem aus Nicht-EU-Ländern ist aber
ein Baustein von vielen
das führt mich zum gürtelinstitut seine
Arbeit stärken wir nochmals deutlich die
weltweiten Goethe-Institute sind lokale
Anlaufstellen die ein erstes positives
Bild von Deutschland vermitteln sie sind
gewissermaßen Vorboten die wesentlich
dazu beitragen dass sie potenzielle
Fachkräfte zum Beispiel aus Indonesien
Costa Rica oder Neuseeland für unsere
deutsche Sprache und Kultur zu
interessieren beginnen denn oft gibt es
sonst gar keine Berührungspunkte zu
Deutschland deshalb haben wir Haushälter
ein Programm des Instituts zur
Fachkräftegewinnung in Mittel und
Südamerika angestoßen und es liegt mir
sehr am Herzen dass wir im Parlament
weiter gemeinsam an den Fachkräfte Thema
arbeiten
hierbei spielen auch die deutsche
Schulen im Ausland eine wichtige Rolle
fast jeder zweite Schüler kommt später
nach Deutschland um hier zu studieren
diese jungen Menschen sind die
Fachkräfte von morgen denn viele von
ihnen bleiben bei uns
außerdem haben die Schulen an denen man
ein deutsches Abitur oder ein
deutsch-diplom erwerben kann eine große
Bedeutung für deutsche Unternehmen mit
Niederlassungen im Ausland denn die
Kinder der im Ausland lebenden Deutschen
müssen auch irgendwo unterrichtet werden
unsere Unternehmen erwirtschaften im
Ausland fast ein Drittel des gesamten
Volkseinkommens das erklärt auch warum
die deutschen Auslandsschulen einen
besonderen Stellenwert haben und deshalb
haben wir uns als Koalition dafür
eingesetzt dass die Schulen weiter
gestärkt werden
insgesamt fördern wir Programme die
Menschen mit verschiedenen Hintergründen
an einen Tisch bringen dazu gehören auch
die internationalen Stipendienprogramme
für Studierende sowie für
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
zum Beispiel des Deutschen Akademischen
Austauschdienstes und der Alexander von
Humboldt-Stiftung
dazu gehören auch
jugendaustauschprogramme wie die
deutschsprachigen jugendkonferenzen oder
der deutsch-türkischen jugendbrücke die
schülerfahrten organisiert
und dazu gehören Austauschprogramme für
Auszubildende auch hier haben wir im
Parlament ein Projekt für
handwerksazubis auf den Weg gebracht
ob Studentin Auszubildender oder
IT-Experte diejenigen die nach
Deutschland kommen wollen brauchen ein
Visum
für viele sind die visa-verfahren
kompliziert und noch mit langen
Wartezeiten verbunden es ist es ist
deshalb eine gute Nachricht das vor zwei
Jahren das Bundesamt für auswärtige
Angelegenheit seine Arbeit aufgenommen
hat nur wenige Kilometer entfernt von
meinem Wahlkreis in Brandenburg an der
Havel das Bundesamt für auswärtige
Angelegenheiten ist eine neue Behörde
und Geschäftsbereich des Auswärtigen
Amtes es unterstützt die deutschen
Auslandsvertretung bei der Bearbeitung
von dieser Antrieben insbesondere im
Bereich der Fachkräfte Einwanderung
allein im letzten Jahr wurden insgesamt
etwa 340.000 Anträge gestellt das sind
im Schnitt fast 1000 pro Tag
um die Abläufe effizienter zu machen
sollen die Verfahren modernisiert werden
weniger Papierformulare mehr
digitalanträge und dafür stellen wir
jetzt Geld bereit
ich möchte zum Schluss noch einmal auf
die humanitäre Hilfe zu sprechen kommen
sie macht über ein Drittel das gesamt
etas des Auswärtigen Amtes aus nämlich
2,7 Milliarden Euro
der Bereich der humanitären Hilfe bleibt
damit ein Schwerpunkt in diesem Etat
hier geht es darum den besonders armen
Ländern zu helfen die Auswirkungen von
Krieg Klimawandel und Hungersnot
abzufedern
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland bleibt
weltweit der zweitgrößte Geber nach den
USA das ist eine klare Haltung seit
vielen Jahren
Deutschland war immer ein verlässlicher
Partner und wird es auch bleiben
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
ich komme zurück auf den Einzelplan 04
und gebe ihnen das Ergebnis der
namentlichen Abstimmung über den Entwurf
eines Gesetzes über die Feststellung des
bundeshaushaltsplans für das
Haushaltsjahr 2023 Haushaltsgesetz 2021
Einzelplan 04 Geschäftsbereich des
Bundeskanzlers und des
Bundeskanzleramtes Drucksachen
310020 aus 31.02 20 aus 35 024 aus 35 26
bekannt abgegebene Stimmkarten 687 mit
Jahr haben gestimmt 387 mit Nein haben
bestimmt 299 Enthaltungen eine damit ist
der Einzelplan 04 angenommen so dann
kommen wir zurück zum Einzelplan 05 und
das Wort der Kollegin syrien-fraktion
die Linke und Sprecherin für
internationale Politik der Linksfraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
Russland bombardiert völkerrechtswidrig
die Ukraine und was macht die
Bundesregierung sie liefert weiter
Waffen an Russland lässt üppige
Wirtschafts- und Finanzhilfen an das
Land weiter fließen und legt Moskau
ledig nicht nah bei seinen Luftangriffen
den Grundsatz der Verhältnismäßigkeit zu
wahren ja sie haben Recht pardon es
stimmt das tut sie nicht es geht ja gar
nicht gegen Russland sondern um ihre
Nato-Partner Türkei
richtigerweise muss es nämlich heißen
die Türkei bombardiert
völkerrechtswidrig Syrien und was macht
die Bundesregierung sie liefert weiter
Waffen an die Türkei es gibt keinen
Waffenexport Stopp lässt übrigens
Wirtschafts- und Finanzhilfen weiter
fließen und legt Ankara lediglich nah
bei seinen Luftangriffen den Grundsatz
der Verhältnismäßigkeit zu wahren und zu
achten und allein an diesem Beispiel
lässt sich ablesen mit welch
keinerlei Maß ihre Außenpolitik hier
misst Frau Werbung und natürlich ist der
Angriffskrieg Russlands zu verurteilen
und die Bombardierung der zivilen
Infrastruktur in der Ukraine ist ganz
klar ein Kriegsverbrechen und dieser
Krieg muss auch deshalb so schnell wie
möglich enden aber genauso zu
verurteilen ist der völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffskrieg der Türkei in Syrien und
da sind sie einfach still und Schweigen
vor sich hin und da finde ich das geht
nicht das muss Konsequenzen haben und es
ist
eben bezeichnet dass man sich global
wenn man sich umhört nicht mehr die
Diplomatie Kennzeichen der deutschen
Außenpolitik ist sondern das größte
Aufrüstungsprogramm nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg und der stetige Ruf nach immer
mehr und immer schwereren Waffen die man
in die Ukraine schicken soll und es
sollte uns doch wirklich nachdenklich
stimmen dass selbst in den USA die rufen
nach einer diplomatischen Lösung im
Ukraine Krieg immer lauter werden wie
jüngst vom Rang höchsten US-General dem
generalstaatschef mag Mille warum hören
wir dies nicht aus dem deutschen
Außenministerium warum scheinen sie
selbst noch die Falken im Weißen Haus
übertreffen zu wollen in ihrer Rhetorik
und wie existenziell eine diplomatische
Lösung in der Ukraine ist war doch an
den Ereignissen beim Raketenbeschuss in
Polen deutlich absehbar
und es ist fatal dass auch Politiker der
Ampelkoalition mit Falschmeldungen mit
dabei waren fast einen dritten Weltkrieg
heraufzubeschwören
während die Presseagentur Associated
Press den Reporter der diese weltweit
verbreitete Falschmeldung fabrizierte
entlassen hat machen Sie hier einfach
weiter als wäre nichts geschehen die
große Mehrheit der Bevölkerung in
Deutschland steht für eine diplomatische
Lösung und erwartet dass die
Außenministerin endlich anfängt zu
arbeiten und eine Initiative für eine
diplomatische Lösung unternimmt und die
Frage nicht deshalb auch in diesem
Zusammenhang warum sie nicht wenigstens
eine Überprüfung ihrer Sanktionspolitik
einleiten in der Antwort auf die Kleine
Anfrage meiner Fraktion hat die
Bundesregierung ja eingestanden dass sie
keine Ahnung hat welche Wirkungen die
Sanktionen im Hinblick auf die
Veränderung der russischen Politik haben
aber das Problem ist dass wir bereits
jetzt sehen dass der Wirtschaftskrieg
den sie neben den Waffenlieferung als
außenpolitisches Instrument einsetzen
massiven Schaden für die Bevölkerung in
Deutschland anrichtet mehr als 300.000
Unternehmen haben in Deutschland
mittlerweile finanzielle Probleme und
daran hängen Millionen von
Arbeitsplätzen seit März 2022 hat sich
die Zahl der Pleitekandidaten um 15,6
Prozent erhöht und frühen das nächste
Jahr droht ein Wirtschaftseinbruch und
sie machen da einfach weiter ich finde
das ungeheuerlich und man gewinnt
man gewinnt auch mittlerweile den
Eindruck und ich muss Ihnen sagen auch
das hört man im globalen Süden dass das
was die deutsche Außenpolitik anpackt
schlicht daneben geht und ich meine
jetzt nicht nur die Bundesregierung dass
sie versucht hat mit einem Kotau vor der
golf-diktatur Katar um Gas zu betteln
ich will Ihnen zwei Beispiele geben die
das illustrieren sie verweigern sich neu
Verhandlungen des versöhnungsabkommens
mit Namibia die von den Nachfahren der
dem Völkermord zum Opfer gefallenen
Menschen in der ehemaligen deutschen
Kolonie dringend eingefordert werden
ebenso wie auch jeder Diskussion und
Reparationen
und dann Mali gestern haben sie den
längsten Rückzug in der jüngeren
deutschen Militärgeschichte auf dem Weg
gebracht die Bundeswehr wird damit
beschäftigt sein die nächsten eineinhalb
Jahre den Abzug aus dem
westafrikanischen Land zu vollziehen
während die Sicherheitslage im prekärer
wird und deshalb sagen wir ganz einfach
die Bundeswehr sollte nicht erst im Mai
2024 abziehen sondern sie sollte jetzt
abziehen und wir brauchen
meine Damen und Herren wir brauchen
dringend eine andere Außenpolitik eine
friedliche Außenpolitik die Stadt auf
Block Konfrontation Aufrüstung und
Stellvertreter Kriege auf Diplomatie auf
Ausgleich und einen starken Sozialstaat
mit einer starken Wirtschaft setzt
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
und damit kommen wir zum nächsten Redner
der sich schon fast aufmacht weil das
ist hier Usus dass man noch wartet bis
man aufgerufen wird vom Bundestags viel
zu Präsidenten bevor man zum Pult geht
Otto Fricke hier an dieses Pool zu
treten Herr Kollege Körber vielleicht
ein kleiner Hinweis sie haben das eben
zu der Frage Haushaltspolitik und mit
den unzufriedenen Ministern gesagt ich
glaube da unterliegt ihre Fraktion
insgesamt einem Irrtum der sich
vielleicht auch den letzten 16 Jahren
gezeigt hat es ist nicht die Aufgabe des
Haushaltsausschusses die Minister
glücklich zu machen es ist die Aufgabe
dafür zu sorgen dass das der
Steuerzahler den Ministerinnen und
Ministern einen vernünftigen Haushalt
zur Verfügung stellt mit dem Sie
arbeiten können und genau das hat die
Ampel getan
meine Damen und Herren
warum und warum machen wir einen
entsprechenden Einzelplan und womit
befasst sich der Einzelplan naja man
kann natürlich dann wieder zu
Shakespeare greifen Cassius sagt das
sehr sehr schön im fünften Akt in der
ersten Szene weil das Los des Lebens
niemals sicher ist lasst uns bedacht
sein auf den schlimmsten Fall und das
ist etwas worüber wir ja eigentlich
reden wir hätten am liebsten eine Welt
in der alles einfach friedlich leicht zu
lösen wäre wir wissen auch und das sage
ich aufgrund meiner Vorrednerin man kann
nicht alles immer nur mit Diplomatie
lösen übrigens wenn man das könnte wäre
die Rede glaube ich auch etwas anders
gewesen denn die zeigt er das nicht
alles mit Diplomatie geht und das ist
die Aufgabe die diese Einzelplan fünf
neben den Einzelplan Verteidigung und
Entwicklung Zusammenarbeit wahrnimmt und
die ja auch gut waren nimmt und da
kommen wir dann schon den zu dem Punkt
was sie gemacht haben meine mit
Berichterstatterin haben es bereits
gesagt wir haben in einem Teil dem
Auswärtigen Amt mehr Geld gegeben wir
haben das aber in Anführungszeichen
nicht getan indem wir zusätzlich gegeben
Geld gegeben haben sondern nachdem wir
etwas gemacht haben was im Haushalt
schon stand und da bin ich dann wieder
bei Cassius da bin ich wieder bei Julius
Cäsar wir haben die Krisenvorsorge in
Höhe von zwei Milliarden aufgelöst und
so damit dafür gesorgt dass beim
Innenminister mit einem kleinen Teil
Einzelplan 23 in größeren und
Auswärtigen Amt in einem größeren Teil
entsprechende Krisenvorsorge dann auch
konkret umgesetzt wird und haben damit
ein Zeichen unserer internationalen
Verantwortung gegeben und entsprechend
ist auch das Feedback positiv und
übrigens Frau Kollegin auch aus dem
Süden unseres Planeten meine Damen und
Herren
meine Damen und Herren ich will auch
noch mal sagen weil immer kommt wofür
gebt ihr denn dann das Geld aus was ist
denn das was heißt das denn humanitäre
Hilfe ja das ist auch das wo dem
konkreten einzelnen Menschen dem Kind
der Mutter dem Vater dem älteren allen
geholfen wird ja aber es ist auch das
dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
Botschaften die zusätzlichen Mittel
haben um humanitäre Hilfe zu ermöglichen
um zu organisieren um die Dinge möglich
zu machen die dann auch vor Ort ankommen
und nicht das Geld am Ende nur für
Verwaltung auszugeben oder hinter
irgendwelchen Mauern zu sitzen auch das
ist die Aufgabe die Aufgabe auch die
entsprechenden Reisen zu ermöglichen um
die ausreisen aus krisenbedingten Region
zu ermöglichen die Möglichkeiten für
Mitarbeiter die wir in die Regionen
hineinzugehen die Sicherheit für
Botschaft Personal all das gehört mit
dazu um all das hat sich dieser Haushalt
gekümmert und ich glaube dass diese
Umbuchungen auch notwendig waren denn
die Herausforderungen die auf uns
zukommen werden im nächsten Jahr von
denen wissen wir alle gar nicht genau
wie sie aussehen werden und wenn jetzt
einer sagt ja ihr habt ja alles
aufgelöst dann sage ich hier nein der
Haushalt hat an ganz vielen Stellen noch
entsprechende res werden nicht nur der
Haushalt des einzelplanes 5 sondern auch
der Gesamthaushalt weil wir eben nicht
genau wissen wie die Zukunft beim Thema
Krisen sein wird und weil uns die
Menschen an der Stelle wichtig sind
Punkt 2 auswärtige Kulturpflege ist alle
schon angesprochen worden wem wir einen
helfen ich bin da sehr froh dass wir da
noch was haben tun können insbesondere
beim Thema DAAD die Frage wie helfen wir
so wohl hier in Deutschland als auch vor
Ort das akademische Ausbildungs
stattfindet dass wir diejenigen dann
haben die mit Verstand aber auch mit
Fähigkeiten immer mehr einen Schritt
ihrer Länder in Richtung Demokratie
hinbekommen das ist wichtig da bin ich
auch sehr froh dass wir das tun wir
haben das
wir haben das ohne große Auflagen
gemacht anders ist es beim
Goethe-Institut und ja ich habe die
Zeitung auch gelesen und ja ich bin seit
2002 im Haushaltsausschuss ich habe kein
Jahr erlebt wo nicht die Frage war ob
Goethe nicht eine gewisse Reform machen
müsste wenn wir aber sagen wir wollen
reformieren dann heißt das nicht wir
wollen es weghaben dann sagen wir damit
nicht es ist schlecht sondern dann geht
es dieser Ampelkoalition und deswegen
hat sie einen Betrag von ursprünglich
zwölf nachher waren es 14 Millionen
gesperrt dann wollen wir besseres Güte
mehr Goethe stärkeres Güte haben aber an
den Stellen die nicht mehr den Aufträgen
vielleicht aus den 70er und 80er Jahren
entsprechen sondern die den Aufträgen
entsprechend die wir in diesem
Jahrzehnten in diesem Jahr 1000 dann
auch wahrnehmen müssen und da bin ich
auch gute Hoffnung dass Goethe diese
Meldung angenommen hat dass da auch
entsprechende Vorschläge kommen wir
haben eine Frist bis August gesetzt wenn
früher schon entsprechende
Reformschritte kommen bin ich gerne
bereit schon über teilauflösungen der
Sperre zu reden aber entscheidend ist
dass das was Kultur und Bildungs nötig
ausmacht was damit verbunden ist für
unser Land auch nach draußen stärker in
einer Art entsprechend kommuniziert wird
wie ist der heutigen Zeit und im
heutigen Land entspricht und wenn das
dann erfolgt und wenn wir dann auch noch
Frau Ministerin für die DGAP das Geld
ausgeben in diesem Jahr bin ich
glücklich herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Brücke
ist der Kollege Roderich Kiese mit der
cdu/c-situation
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren es ist die Aufgabe dieser Debatte
Herr Kollege Fricke die kühlen
Kalkulation des Haushaltsausschusses
klar und strategisch einzuordnen und das
System Kollegen Körber wirklich gut
gelungen
das ist ein Haushalt wie er heute früh
deklariert wurde der Zeitenwende liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen was bedeutet
denn die Zeitenwende für Estland oder
für Georgien oder für die Ukraine in
diesen Ländern ist die Zeitenwende
bereits viel früher angekommen in
Estland 2007 mit dem Cyberangriff
Russlands auf die Infrastruktur in
Georgien 2008 mit dem Krieg Russlands
gegen Georgien und 2014 mit der
völkerrechtswidrigen Annexion der Krim
und den Krieg in der Ostukraine in der
Ukraine und in Deutschland hat er
damalige Bundespräsident mit dem
damaligen Außenminister und heutigen
Bundespräsidenten und der
Verteidigungsministerin versucht die
Zeiten Wände einzuläuten indem er bei
der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz 2014
gesagt hat Deutschland müsste früher
entschiedener und substanzieller handeln
nun hat das gedauert bis zum 27 februar
und wir alle wissen dass die Rede
beeindruckend war nur die Umsetzung
nicht und Frau Außenministerin sie haben
harte Weichenstellungen vor sich nicht
alles haben sie zu verantworten und
deshalb müssen wir auch in Demut sehen
dass wir vieles in der Vergangenheit
nicht gesehen haben aber trotz aller
Demut jetzt mutig vorangehen müssen und
dazu haben wir ein paar Gedanken und ich
möchte Ihnen drei vorstellen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Europa ist zum Testfeld geworden
seit 2007 zum Testfeld hybrider
Kriegsführung und der Rückkehr des
Krieges Europa ist zum Testfeld geworden
einer systemischen Auseinandersetzung wo
Russland der Sturm ist aber China der
Klimawandel und um das zu verstehen
müssen wir uns anders aufstellen und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass die 141
Staaten die den russischen Angriffskrieg
auf die Ukraine verurteilt haben von der
regelbasierten internationalen Ordnung
überzeugt bleiben und werden und
deswegen muss das Kanzleramt begreifen
dass man Führung nicht einfach nur
proklamieren kann sondern Führung
praktisch umsetzen muss weil Deutschland
Scharnierfunktion hat im Verständnis der
Bedrohung Osteuropas Mitteleuropas und
der anderen Sorgen in Südeuropa das ist
unsere Führungsaufgabe
und das führt mich zum zweiten Gedanken
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
zweite Gedanke ist dass die Zeitenwende
in praktische Politik in praktisches
Handeln umgesetzt werden muss hier
begrüßen wir der Kollege Körber des
angesprochen das in ihrem Haushalt Frau
Außenministerin über drei Milliarden
Euro vorgesehen sind für Frieden
Stabilisierung aber besonders auch für
humanitäre Hilfe das begrüßen wir aber
Geld allein reicht nicht es ist die
Frage der Menschenrechte der Stärkung
der Kultur die Frage der regelbasierten
internationalen Ordnung und um diese zu
verdeutlichen müssen wir alles erreichen
dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt
und das führt mich
zum dritten
Gedanken
und hier muss ich sehr klar
unterstreichen müssen wir uns auch
unbequemen Wahrheiten Stellen ich möchte
drei kurz anreisen erstens der Iran sie
waren sehr zögerlich Frau
Außenministerin sie haben es jetzt
geändert aber die Waage Aussicht auf ein
nuklearabkommen mit dem Iran dürfen wir
nicht die Zivilgesellschaft
vernachlässigen viel wichtiger wäre es
doch wenn der Iran demokratisiert einen
Regimewechsel aus eigener Kraft erreicht
und dann ein nuklearabkommen erreicht
als dass wir
zurückhaltend und mutlos versuchen ein
Abkommen zu verhandeln dass der Iran nie
eingehen wird weil der Iran ähnlich wie
Nordkorea nicht das Schicksal der
Ukraine teilen möchte die nuklear 1994
abgerüstet haben und nun dieses
furchtbare Schicksal erleiden und
deshalb
Zivilgesellschaft zuerst Stärken im Iran
zweite unbequeme Wahrheit sie haben sich
dem Rat unserer Dienste Folgen sehr klar
gegen den Verkauf eines Terminals des
Hamburger Herzens ausgesprochen zwar
auch richtig so sechs Ministerien dieses
Hauses haben sich dagegen ausgesprochen
das kanzelamt hat anders entschieden und
ich erwarte von dieser Regierung und wir
als Union erwarten von dieser Regierung
mehr Mut gegenüber dem Kanzleramt
es geht doch auch darum dass wir uns
darauf einstellen müssen dass Italien
und andere Länder die mühsam die
chinesischen
Verkaufsversuche kaufversuche abgewehrt
haben dass die sich jetzt enttäuscht
sehen der Hafen von Triest ist nach
Hamburg verkauft worden und plötzlich
wird ein Teil des Hamburger Hafens
zugänglich für chinesische Cyber
Spionage und die dritte Wahrheit liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen unbequeme
Wahrheit ist wenn wir die regelbasierte
internationale Ordnung stärken wollen
darf die Ukraine diesen Krieg nicht nur
nicht verlieren sie mussten Krieg
gewinnen und gewinnen heißt dass wir
alles tun diesen Krieg zu verkürzen
indem die Ukraine alles erhält was sie
benötigt dass sie auch das Gelände dass
sie gewonnen hat halten kann und dass
ihre Soldatinnen und Soldaten nicht in
diesen furchtbaren Krieg mit
veraltendeten Systemen ihr Leben
verlieren
Schützenpanzer Marder und selbst die 50
Jahre alten Kampfpanzer Leopard gewähren
ein anderes Überleben der Besatzungen
als die auf 8000 Grad im Inneren sich
erhitzenden explodierenden alten
sowjetischen Modelle da sind wir in
einer Verantwortung auch vor den Witwen
die wissen dass eine Lieferung das
Überleben ihrer Männer eher
gewährleistet hätte die Ukraine
kämpft hier für uns und jeder hier in
diesem Haus und in der Bundesregierung
und in den anderen Oppositionsparteien
die für einen Waffenstillstand gegen die
Ukraine werben Verben dafür dass
Russland sich erholt den Krieg gegen
eine rumpf-ukraine fortsetzt und dann
das war zu machen was sie im Februar
diesen Jahres verkündet haben den Krieg
gegen Moldau und gegen das Baltikum
vorzusetzen weil sie glauben wir sind
schwach und Frau Außenministerin wir
erwarten von Ihnen hier mehr Härte sie
haben einen guten Satz geprägt
Diplomatie und Härte das ist das was
eine andere Politik ist als in der
Vergangenheit die Bundesrepublik hat
lange nur auf Diplomatie gesetzt auf
softpower was wir brauchen ist die
Kombination von Diplomatie und Härte das
ist Smart Power nur dann werden wir
glaubwürdig auch die regelbasierte
internationale Ordnung unterstützen wir
müssen erreichen
das Länder wie Russland wie Iran wie
China oder Nordkorea nicht Nachahmer
finden wenn die Ukraine verlieren würde
dann noch eine ganz neue Allianz zu bei
neuer Krieg beginnen würde wir müssen
erreichen dass die Ukraine gewinnt und
diese Länder isoliert bleiben und sich
neu ordnen herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Roderich
käsewetter war das und die
bundesaußenministerin wurde ja schon
häufiger angesprochen und jetzt wird sie
selber zu ihrem Einzelplan 054
Ausstellung beziehen
[Applaus]
herr Präsident sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Besucherinnen und
Besucher wir brauchen Partner auf die
wir uns verlassen können das ist der
eindringlichste Satz den ich immer
wieder als Außenministerin im letzten
Jahr gehört habe egal an welchen Ort ich
gereist bin nicht nur in der Ukraine
nicht nur im Baltikum sondern auch in
Asien in Afrika im Nahen Osten und erst
recht auf dieser Klimakonferenz denn für
viele Partner außerhalb Europas steht
Russlands brutaler Angriffskrieg eben
nicht an erster Stelle ihrer Sicherheit
sondern ihre Sicherheit ist zentral
durch die Klimakrise durch dürren
durchfluten durch Vertreibung aufgrund
des Klimawandels gezeichnet
die Wahrheit die wir in diesem alles
andere als einfachen ich würde sagen
größtenteils furchtbaren ja erleben
mussten ist dass Russlands Angriffskrieg
bestehende Wunden noch weiter
aufgerissen hat
insbesondere mit Blick auf die weltweite
Ernährungskrise deshalb stellen wir noch
in diesem Haushalt noch im Haushalt 2022
eine Milliarde zusätzliche Gelder für
Linderung der globalen
Nahrungsmittelkrise bereit und ja ich
weiß dass der Bedarf deutlich größer ist
er liegt laut food Programm bei 44
Milliarden aber ich möchte an dieser
Stelle auch einmal sagen
deutschland hat mit Blick auf die
humanitäre Hilfe innerhalb der letzten
zehn Jahre und das umfasst alle
demokratischen Parteien hier im
Deutschen Bundestag ihre humanitäre
Hilfe mehr als per 20-facht
2023 wird sie das haben einige Vorredner
bereits erwähnt bei 2,7 Milliarden Euro
liegen und dafür möchte ich Ihnen allen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus dem
Haushaltsausschuss aber allen anderen
auch die in den letzten Jahren und in
diesem Jahr daran mitgewirkt haben
wirklich von Herzen danken weil das ist
das Vertrauen was Deutschland dann
weiter auch in der Welt genießen kann
und Frau Papenburg und andere haben es
angesprochen das umfasst eben nicht nur
humanitäre Hilfe sondern auch
Verlässlichkeit bei Stipendien bei
Bildungs- und bei Kulturarbeit und ich
höre das von unterschiedlichen Ecken
dann doch immer mal wieder Deutschland
ist viel stärkste Volkswirtschaft warum
müssen wir eigentlich zweitstärkster
globaler Geber sein es müssen wir nicht
sein wir können uns das natürlich auch
ganz anders aussuchen aber ich glaube
dieses Jahr das sollten Sie sich von
Rechtsaußen auch überlegen hat deutlich
gezeigt wir werden unseren Frieden
unsere Freiheit unsere Sicherheit in
Europa niemals alleine verteidigen
können niemals alleine mit Waffen
niemals alleine mit Diplomatie sondern
auch wir brauchen die internationale
Gemeinschaft und deswegen will ich stolz
darauf dass unser Land zweitgrößter
weltweiter ist
wir werden daher unsere weltweite
Zusammenarbeit weiter ausbauen das gilt
insbesondere auch mit dem Engagement im
Sahel wir haben gestern gemeinsam mit
anderen ministerkolleginnen entschieden
dass wir unser Engagement im Sahel in
dieser so krisengebeutelten Regionen neu
aufstellen werden gemeinsam mit unseren
internationalen Partnern wir wollen in
diesem Zusammenhang dem Deutschen
Bundestag vorschlagen und dass man da
steht bekanntermaßen im Mai an und ist
auch gemeinsam mit Ihnen intensiv zu
diskutieren nach zehn Jahren im Rahmen
einer neu aufgestellten Sahel Strategie
auch unser Engagement aus minusma
strukturiert zurückzuziehen sie haben
gerade gesagt dass es der längste
Rückzug den sie kennen ja weil wir
verlässliche Partner sind weil es das
Gegenteil von einer vertrauensvollen
Außenpolitik wäre Hals über Kopf zu
sagen wir haben uns im übrigen anders
überlegt wir haben uns anders überlegt
obwohl wir anderen Ländern die banglade
anderen afrikanischen Staaten die beim
nächsten Mal engagiert sind sie waren ja
selber da Frau
anders überlegt wir haben euch zwar
versprochen noch ein Jahr Transport
drüber Brauer zu stellen aber bei uns in
Deutschland wird gerade ein bisschen
schwierig deswegen ziehen wir uns jetzt
Hals über Kopf zurück nein das ist das
Gegenteil von verantwortungsvoller und
vor allem vertrauensvoller Außenpolitik
deshalb ist unser Vorschlag dass wir
insbesondere die Wahlen die wir immer
wieder eingefordert haben weil bei
dieser Mission geht es um
Friedenssicherung um Schritte zur
Demokratie dass wir insbesondere die
Wahlen die hoffentlich sowohl des
versprochen im nächsten Jahr und im
Frühjahr 24 anstehen dass wir diese noch
mit begleiten und zugleich machen wir
deutlich auch in den Vorbereitungen der
nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie un
Friedensmission bleiben zentraler
Bestandteil unserer
außenentwicklungssicherheitspolitik
unfriedensmissionen dienen auch unser
eigenen Sicherheit hier bei uns
und das Leben ist komplex und wenn es
schwarz-weiß und alles nur einfach wäre
dann bräuchten wir so intensive Debatten
gar nicht führen natürlich bedeutet
Sicherheit in der Sahelzone genauso wie
bei uns eine absolut vernetzte
Sicherheit wenn wir über die
Unterstützung der Bundeswehr reden
müssen wir auch immer über
Bildungspolitik reden wir müssen über
Klimapolitik reden wir erleben auch
dramatische Art und Weise warum uns
Länder wie zum Beispiel Niger eins der
ärmsten Länder der Welt und trotzdem mit
aller Kraft dabei demokratisch zu
bleiben warum uns Länder wie
Veganer oder auch Kenia auf dem G7
Außenminister treffen so gebeten haben
so drauf gedrungen haben dass wir vor
Ort bleiben weil sie wissen wenn sich
die terroristischen Strömung die
natürlich darauf bauen das ist in der
Bildungsarbeit das ist in der klimarbeit
nicht weiter vorangeht weil sie dann vor
allen Dingen rekrutieren können deswegen
ist es so für uns so wichtig dass wir
diesen vernetzten Ansatz zusammendenken
auch wenn es schwierig ist bei uns auch
wenn bei uns gerade die Inflation weiter
nach oben geht
und wir haben daher in diesem
Zusammenhang weil die Welt nun mal
vernetzt ist zum Glück leben wir nicht
in einer abgeschotteten Welt haben wir
deswegen gemeinsam mit der
entwicklungsministerin insbesondere aber
auch der Umweltministerin im
Landwirtschaftsminister dem
Wirtschaftsminister weil wir breit
aufgestellt sind als Klima Außenpolitik
haben wir auf dieser Klimakonferenz so
dafür gekämpft dass wir endlich unsere
CO2-Emission mindern und zugleich ein
neues Kapitel in der Klimagerechtigkeit
aufschlagen sie rufen jetzt rein kein
Mensch braucht Klima Außenpolitik doch
weil ansonsten gefährden wir unsere
eigene Sicherheit und wir haben
natürlich auch da überlegt dass auf
einer Klimakonferenz die Geostrategie im
Hintergrund die ganze Zeit betrieben
wird und deswegen hat unsere China
Strategie ganz viel mit unserer Klima-
Präsenz das ist ein Land wie Sambia
plötzlich dafür spricht das
Industriestaat nicht weiter ihre
Emissionen senken sollten da fragt man
sich wie kann denn das eigentlich sein
wenn sie einmal zuhören würden anstatt
dauernd reinzubringen kann ich Ihnen das
im nächsten Satz erklären was hat das
mit China zu tun als ich dann der
chinesische Vertreter gemeldet hat hat
der Sambia gedankt und dann fragt man
sich auf was hat das jetzt mit China zu
tun ja die Menschenrechtsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung war gerade in Samia und
kann berichten wer den Flughafen in
Sambia finanziert hat nämlich China
alles hängt mit allen in dieser
komplizierten komplexen Welt zusammen
und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir
Klimapolitik dass wir humanitäre Hilfe
dass Sie unsere China Strategie zusammen
denken und nicht das eine gegen das
andere ausspielen und dafür
zählt für mich auch dafür zählt für mich
auch dass wir Diplomatie und
militärisches Engagement nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen es gibt Momente
im Leben da kann man sich nicht wünschen
dass dieser Krieg vorbeigeht sondern es
gibt Momente im Leben da muss man sich
entscheiden auf welcher Seite man steht
auf der Seite des Rechts oder auf der
Seite des Unrechts auf der Seite des
Angreifers oder auf der Seite des
angegriffenen wir haben uns hier zum
Glück als demokratische Parteien am 24
Februar bzw am Wochenende danach
gemeinsam entstehen entschieden wir
stehen auf der Seite der Ukraine auf der
Seite der Menschen in der Ukraine und
auch da kann ich sagen ich bin stolz
dass ich ein Land repräsentieren darf
das ist ein Privileg ein Land
repräsentieren darf wo die allergrößte
Mehrheit in unserem Land sagt das ist
nicht einfach mit den Energiepreisen es
ist wahnsinnig schwierig wenn die
Lebensmittelpreise auch noch steigen wo
sie zu recht kritische Fragen an ihre
Regierung stellen aber zugleich eine
89-jährige Rentnerin genauso wie eine
neunjährige Schülerin sagt diesem Winter
werden wir weiter an der Seite der
Ukraine stehen weil eben die
Bombardierung nicht aufhört trotz
Getreide Deal trotz Diplomatie über
saporica sondern gezielt Infrastruktur
angegriffen wird und wir lassen nicht zu
dass die Strategie des Verhungerns und
des Erfrierens von Russland erfolgreich
herzlichen Dank sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
die
bundesaußenministerin Anna-Lena beerbock
hat hier unter anderem noch mal die
Strategie zum Rückzug aus Mali bis zum
Mai 2024 er verteidigt aber natürlich
auch ihr Steckenpferd die Klima
Außenpolitik Markus frohnmeyer spricht
jetzt für die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
Frau bergdox hier haben gerade gesagt
sie stehen an der Seite der Ukraine egal
was mit den Bürgern in Deutschland
passiert mit der neunjährigen Schülerin
oder mit der Rentnerin ich sage Ihnen
mal was wir von der AFD wir stehen an
der Seite der deutschen Bevölkerung und
wir machen Politik für deren Interessen
mehr als die Hälfte der Ausgaben für das
Auswärtige Amt ihnen der Sicherung von
Frieden und Stabilität aber kümmert sich
Frau baerbock auch um Frieden und
Stabilität in der Ostsee als am 26
September sowohl Nord Stream eins als
auch Nord Stream 2 in die Luft gesprengt
wurden was haben sie da gemacht ich
erinnere mal daran als ein paar Stücke
ukrainische raketenkrümmer auf
polnisches Gebiet niedergegangen sind
und es auch leider zwei Tote gegeben hat
da war die gesamte NATO alarmiert die
polnische Regierung hat sich sogar
überlegt ob sie den die Vorstufe zum
Bündnisfall ausruft bärburg hat noch am
gleichen Abend per Twitter verlautbart
dass sie sich in enger Abstimmung mit
den polnischen Verbündeten befindet aber
was hat die Außenministerin gemacht als
es einen Angriff auf eine einen Angriff
eine terroristische Sabotage gegen die
Nord streamleitungen gab nichts sie
haben nichts gemacht auch heute wissen
wir immer noch nicht dieses Haus weiß es
noch nicht was da eigentlich vorgefallen
ist Schweigen im Walde
da war die Außenministerin die sonst
immer für Belehrungen gut ist ganz still
und mehr noch bis heute hat die
Regierung nichts unternommen um weiter
Aufklärung zu betreiben
3,4 Milliarden Euro für Sicherung und
Frieden und Stabilität
und
nichts wenn einer der actpfeiler der
deutschen Wirtschafts- und
Energieversorgung in die Luft gesprengt
wird die viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft auf
der Erde das haben sie gerade selber
auch bemerkt die ist entweder unfähig
das sehen wir dann wenn Sie zum Beispiel
Taucher an die Ostsee schicken den die
notwendige Ausrüstung fehlen um 70 Meter
tief tauchen zu können und Aufklärung zu
betreiben oder das ist die andere
Vermutung die wir langsam haben sie
wollen halt gar nicht aufklären weil wir
immer noch Stream 2 in die Luft
gesprengt hat der hat eigentlich ihr
grünes Parteiprogramm umgesetzt Frau
bärbock
sie haben Deutschland abhängig machen
wollen von flatterstrom und Wasserstoff
und wissen sie das ist uns nicht in Gang
da war eine ganz klammheimliche Freude
des parlamentarischen arms der letzten
Generation also ihrer Partei der Grünen
als nordstream in die Luft geflogen ist
und wenn ich mir ihr Instagram Account
anschaue ihre Stories immerhin tanzen
sie nicht das ist schon mal was dann
scheinen sie sich für alles mögliche auf
der Welt zu interessieren Multikulti in
Kanada Feminismus in Afghanistan
Klimaschutz in Ägypten waffengeschenke
an die Ukraine Bekämpfung von
Rechtsextremismus im Ausland bei
gleichzeitiger Streichungen Streichung
der Dialog fördernden
auslandskulturarbeit nur deutsche
Interessen dazu wird man in den
Instagram Stories der Außenministerin
nichts finden denn ihre Außenpolitik
verfährt nach dem Grundsatz sich zitiere
wörtlich ich zitiere sie wörtlich egal
was meine deutschen Wähler denken das
ist wertebasierte feministische
Außenpolitik von der immer alle reden
wir sagen Schluss damit
wenn die Ukraine von seinem Nachbarn
angegriffen wird dann gibt es eine
sanktionsorgie wenn Aserbaidschan
Armenien bombardiert dann gibt es keine
Sanktionen im Gegenteil da machen Sie
Frau bärbock einen gaststil einen dicken
gasziel mit Baku wenn im Iran die Frauen
das Kopftuch Kopftuch ablegen dann freut
sich diese Regierung wenn aber in
Deutschland jemand etwas gegen
Verschleierung sagt dann klopft der
Haldenwang an der Tür wenn der Russe
bombt dann rufen sie nach Den Haag wenn
US-Präsident Obama wir erinnern uns
hunderte von Menschen illegal mit
Drohnen angreifen dann darf er sich
einen Friedensnobelpreis in die Vitrine
stellen und ganz Werte bewegt haben
damals die Grünen erklärt Renate Künast
und Jürgen das sei ein Signal des
Aufbruchs und eine Aufforderung zur
Abrüstung ich glaube Deutschland hat
genug von dieser Doppelmoral von dieser
Werte passierten feministischen
Außenpolitik wir sagen ganz klar keine
Einmischungen mehr in die inneren
Angelegenheiten anderer Staaten Handel
und wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit aber
uns nicht in Abhängigkeiten begeben
Schutz deutscher Schlüsselindustrien vor
ausländischen übernahmen und Schluss vor
allem Schluss mit der arroganten und
belehrenden grünen Außenpolitik meine
Damen und Herren
und Sie müssen gar nicht so brüllen
irgendwann
[Applaus]
markus frohnmeyer war das von der
afd-fraktion
nächster Redner nächste Rednerin ist
Michelle Müntefering sie ist Mitglied
des Auswärtigen Ausschusses für die
SPD-Fraktion aber eine Vielzahl von
Zwischenrufen verwirren nicht nur die
Stenografen sondern auch das Präsidium
auch wenn Emotionen hochkochen auch wenn
es manchmal wirklich schwer erträglich
ist bei allen Rednern ist das gelingt
nicht der Fall wir sollten doch den
Deutschen Bundestag zu Debatten
also warum sie jetzt gerade Lachen
verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht
verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht aber noch
einmal der Deutsche Bundestag sollte
schon dokumentieren dass er die
Debattenkultur wirklich hochhält und
nicht durch nicht durch zu viele
Zwischenrufe die Debatte stören also als
nächstes
als nächstes hat
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident erstmal
ganz herzlichen Dank dass Sie hier das
Plenum wieder dazu aufrufen zur
Debattenkultur zurückzukommen in der Tat
kann ich nur sagen die Vorrede war
wirklich schwer erträglich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren auf den Ringen
es gibt noch gute Nachrichten in dieser
Welt und auch hier im Plenum und die
wesentliche in dieser Debatte ist
deutschland übernimmt Verantwortung
Verantwortung auch gerade in der Welt
und eine gute Nachricht für mich und
auch für viele hier die daran gearbeitet
haben ist auch dass die auswärtige
Kultur und Bildungspolitik nicht gekürzt
wird und nach dem ersten Entwurf des
Auswärtigen Amtes sage ich mal
vorsichtig war das nicht ganz klar aber
diese grundsätzliche Entscheidung der
Koalition des Haushaltsausschusses den
insgesamt den Haushalt des Auswärtigen
Amtes anwachsen zu lassen ist richtig
und ganz wichtig
das war aber auch hier in den letzten
Wochen eine Kraftanstrengung eine
gemeinsame des Parlaments die Regierung
auch davon zu überzeugen dass es völlig
falsch wäre
zivilgesellschaftliche Bande zu
beschneiden aber diese Botschaft ist
angekommen lieber Kollege Fricke
manchmal muss man ja auch als
parlamentministerin und Minister zu
ihrem Glück ein bisschen bewegen und
dann fühlt man sich ich möchte ihren
Shakespeare um Brecht ergänzen ein
bisschen wie in rechts drei groschenoper
wenn die Not am größten ist die Rettung
am nächsten ich danke jedenfalls
ausdrücklich allen meiner SPD-Fraktion
besonders die geholfen haben dabei dass
wir die gut angelegte Milliarde für die
Mittler die genannt worden sind hier
auch zur Verfügung stellen können der
Einsatz vieler Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hat gezeigt der Deutsche Bundestag setzt
nicht nur auf Werte in Worten sondern
auf Werte durch Taten möchte auch mal
ein Beispiel bringen für dem Programme
die hier angesprochen worden sind im
September haben wir uns als
Unterausschuss als fachpolitikerinnen
und Fachpolitiker mit
zivilgesellschaftlichen Organisationen
ausgetauscht die wir über das
akbp-programm östliche Partnerschaft
fördern mit dabei war unter anderem die
belarussische Organisation Wiesener was
so viel wie Frühling bedeutet eine
Menschenrechtsorganisation mit Sitz in
Minsk in aus Belarus die politischen
Gefangenen und ihren Familien
finanzielle und rechtliche Hilfe
zukommen lässt ihr Gründer aliaski
gehörte zu der Gruppe von
Menschenrechtlern die in diesem Jahr mit
dem Friedensnobelpreis ausgezeichnet
worden sind die beiden weiteren
Preisträger Memorial das Center vor
libertys wurden ebenfalls durch die akbp
durch eines unserer Programme gefördert
und ich meine davon brauchen wir mehr
und nicht weniger weil das Menschen sind
die anderen Menschen helfen wenn die Not
am größten ist sie wissen Freiheit und
Frieden sind eben keine
Selbstverständlichkeiten aber es sollte
für uns eine Selbstverständlichkeit sein
sie zu unterstützen und weiter zu
fördern liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Prioritätensetzung ja werden wir
weiterentwickeln müssen das ist die akbp
so eine Art nicht militärische
Komponente der Zeiten Wände und ich
meine liebe Frau Außenministerin wir
sollten Sie auch in die nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie mit einbetten sie
haben ja gesagt bei der
Auftaktveranstaltung zur Entwicklung der
nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie
Sicherheitspolitik ist mehr als Militär
plus Diplomatie und ich finde es würde
uns gut anstehen dass auch mit zur
integrieren
denn genauso wie free trade noch lange
keinen Fairtrade ist stünde eine
Diplomatie die das Leben der Menschen
ausblendet auf brüchigem Fundament und
nicht zuletzt hilft uns auch der
Austausch der Zivilgesellschaften dabei
die Herausforderungen unserer Zeit zum
Meistern von Sprachkursen für Menschen
schon bevor sie nach Deutschland kommen
bis hin zu Stipendien für Menschen aus
der Ukraine liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es gibt noch gute Nachrichten
in diesen Zeiten auch wenn sie manchmal
schwer zu entdecken sind und sie es auch
seltener in die großen Schlagzeilen
schaffen wenn sie nicht gerade
Nobelpreise bekommen wir sollten aber
sehr genau darauf achten nicht nur auf
den großen Auftritt sondern auf den
dauerhaften und Städten Einsatz denn
damit investieren wir in die wichtigste
Währung der Welt in vertrauen
und zum Schluss noch eine kurze
Bemerkung ich weiß sehr genau wie viele
diplomatinnen und Diplomaten von Sao
Paulo bis London hier am Werderschen
Markt sich einsetzen für eine gute
Außenpolitik allen ihnen herzlichen Dank
für ihre Arbeit aber ganz besonders
sende ich von diesem Pult aus Grüße an
die die mit und für uns arbeiten für
eine multilaterale regelbasierte
Weltordnung lasst uns die Wahrheit sagen
und gut letztes tschüss herzlichen Dank
Michelle Müntefering war das hier für
die sozialdemokratenister Redner ist
Ulrich Lechte der außenpolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident der Klaus meiner eigenen
Fraktion war auch schon größer aber ich
hoffe ich werde das jetzt ausgleichen
können
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
an den Kollegen Kiesewetter gleich zu
Beginn
sei gerichtet das Kanzleramt also der
Kopf unserer Bundesregierung ist nicht
wie das Mordor aus Herr der Ringe
sondern das ist der Teamkapitän und wir
einigen uns dann über unsere Minister
mit dem Kanzler und da kommen dann die
besten Entscheidungen für Deutschland
heraus
und wenn ich allen Rednern so zuhöre
wenn ich allen Rednern so zuhöre gerade
der
Opposition hat man immer das Gefühl wir
hätten volle Panzerschränke gefunden als
wir in die Regierung eingetreten sind
das Gegenteil bei der Fall ist war alles
weg es war alles leer ihr habt bei
Corona wirklich alles rausgepulvert was
rauszupulvern war und wir versuchen
momentan als FDP bei allen Krisen dieser
Welt die ausgabenwünsche der Ministerien
und alle wollen ja Geld ausgeben
schaffen wir es tatsächlich die
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten ich gebe euch
Brief und Segel wenn die groko
weitergeführt worden wäre dann hätten
wir dieses Jahr Ausgabenprogramme ohne
Ende und die Schuldenbremse werden
niemals 2023 eingehalten worden und bei
aller Liebe wiR haben 100 Milliarden
auch für die Bundeswehr jetzt ein
Sondervermögen aufgebracht die Union
erzählt überall wir würden Schulden
machen ohne Ende habe ich heute auch
wieder gehört und der Herr
produktionsführer erzählt das auch
ständig es waren ja nicht nur die
Panzerschränke leer sollen die Depots
der Bundeswehr sind auch leer wir haben
keine Reifen wir haben keine Munition
wir haben gar nichts und wir versuchen
das momentan aufzufüllen und das kostet
halt schlicht und ergreifend mal Geld
also die Botschaft des heutigen Tages
und da bleibe ich als Redner meiner
Partei dabei ohne FDP keine
Schuldenbremse ohne FDP einfach Ausgaben
ohne Ende und das ist die bittere
Wahrheit und ich bin dankbar ich bin
dankbar all unseren Hauseltern und
gerade auch Otto fricket der sich dieses
Mal ganz neu mit dem Auswärtigen
beschäftigt hat und dem Einzelplan 05
das bei aller Freundschaft wie es
geschafft haben die Ausgaben des
Auswärtigen Amtes dort zu halten wo sie
sind und gerade im Bereich der
humanitären Hilfe es geschafft haben
dass wir als Deutschland unseren
Verpflichtungen der Welt weiter
Nachkommen das ist der einzige Weg den
man gehen konnte und dafür bin ich
dankbar und ich bin auch gleichzeitig
dankbar der SPD und den Grünen dass wir
es geschafft haben in unseren
Koalitionsvertrag reinzuschreiben dass
wir künftig unsere Mittel nicht mehr so
ihr Marken wie wir es früher getan haben
sondern uns an den Grand bargen von 2016
halten und 30 Prozent für humanitäre
Hilfe zum Beispiel in Zukunft an ihrem
Markt machen und dementsprechend oder
seitlich ihr Marken und dementsprechend
unseren Verpflichtungen nachkommen damit
geben wir allen Hilfsorganisationen auf
dieser Welt das entsprechende Wasser
unterm Kiel was Sie benötigen um
vernünftig durch die Stürme der Zeit zu
fahren vielen Dank
Ulrich leichte war das hat hier die
humanitäre Hilfe auch ja schon
angesprochen Michael Brandt ist der
Sprecher für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe der Unionsfraktion
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wer erleben gerade jeden Tag in
dramatischer Art und Weise wie eine
barbarische und mittelalterliche Form
der Kriegsführung nicht auf Eroberung
sondern auch auf Vernichtung der
Lebensgrundlagen für Millionen von
Menschen zielt das ist nicht nur
militärisch eine für Europa neue
beziehungsweise alte Ära es ist die
Rückkehr zu einer schlimmen barbarischen
Zeit unsere politische Reaktion auf
diese Herausforderung ist von
strategischer Bedeutung
humanitäre Hilfe ist nicht hier nicht
Hilfe in Not allein sondern auch Hilfe
bei Prävention sie ist strategischer
Pfeiler zur Sicherung und
Wiederherstellung von Stabilität und
Sicherheiten Europa denn Putins
Vernichtungskrieg soll Millionen von
Flüchtlingen nach Polen Deutschland und
andere Länder vertreiben und das Feuer
freie Europa die stabilisieren und
deutlicher sagen wir dem Kriegsjahren im
Gremmel dieses verbrecherische Kalkül
wird scheitern Menschlichkeit und
Zivilisation werden gegen diese Barbarei
am Ende siegen
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
tapfere und beeindruckende Volk der
Ukraine das um sein Überleben kämpft
braucht nicht nur politische und
militärische Hilfe sondern massiv
humanitäre Hilfe die Hilfsbereitschaft
unserer polnischen Nachbarn für die
Flüchtlinge schlicht großartig für diese
große Geste möchte ich auch im Namen
dieses Hauses den Menschen in Polen
ausdrücklich unseren großen Respekt und
auch die Dankbarkeit aussprechen
für den Frieden in Europa ist es von
strategischer Bedeutung dass unsere
Bereitschaft zur Hilfe als Staat wie
auch die großartige Hilfsbereitschaft
unserer Bevölkerung erhalten und auch
gefördert wird und hier gilt gerade für
Deutschland die Ukraine und der Nachbarn
nicht nur mit warmen Worten sondern auch
mit massiver humanitärer Hilfe zu
unterstützen und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen umso mehr ist die von
Außenministerin Werbung vorgeschlagene
Kürzungen im Regierungsentwurf der
humanitärenhilfe ein fatales Signal und
liebe Kollegin Müntefering ich bin Ihnen
dankbar dass sie als Einzige das in der
Debatte angesprochen haben denn es gab
in den vergangenen Regierungen immer den
Konsens das aufgrund der Notwendigkeit
der Dauer und der Anzahl von Krisen auf
der Welt wir unserer Verantwortung
gerecht werden und Frau Ministerin sie
finden freundliche Worte für die Ukraine
und für Polen mit ihrer geplanten
drastischen Kürzungen der humanitären
Hilfe haben sie diese eigenen Worte
Lügen gestraft sie haben damit nicht nur
der Glaubwürdigkeit ihres Amtes sondern
schlimmer der Glaubwürdigkeit
Deutschlands geschadet und die Wahrheit
ist erst der öffentliche Druck erst die
Initiative der cdu/csu wir haben ja den
Antrag gestellt wir haben Vorschläge auf
den Tisch gelegt die die Ampelkoalition
abgelehnt hat ich erinnere an die erste
Lesung an die Beratung im Ausschuss erst
diese Initiative und der öffentliche
Druck auch humanitäre Hilfe erfahrener
NGOs der Partner der Vereinten Nationen
hat erst die Kehrtwende eingeleitet
zurück zu einer verantwortlichen Politik
statt der von der Bundesregierung
vorgeschlagenen Kürzungen von über 500
Millionen Euro stehen nun über 700
Millionen Euro mehr zur Verfügung um das
Minimum an humanitärer Hilfe abzusichern
von der Ukraine über die globale
Nahrungsmittelkrise und anderen Krisen
das hat natürlich die Partner der
humanitären Hilfe nicht verunsichert
sondern auch die Planbarkeit die
Verlässlichkeit der humanitären Hilfe
stark herausgefordert und es sorgt
natürlich dafür dass wissen wir alle die
mit humanitärer Hilfe zu tun haben dass
wir dort auch steigende Preise haben bei
den Lebensmitteln Preisen wenn ich
rechtzeitig dort auch Nahrung eingekauft
wird und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
man muss sich das noch mal vor Augen
halten einen solchen Regierungsentwurf
vorzulegen ausgerechnet in der größten
humanitären Krise in Europa nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg und einer Club einer
drohenden globalen Hungerkatastrophe ich
kann nur sagen in dieser Debatte die
Selbstwahrnehmung der Koalition und die
Realität die klaffen hier schon ziemlich
weit auseinander
Deutschland muss ein strategisches
Interesse daran behalten ein humanitärer
Riese zu bleiben diese Bundesregierung
wollte uns auf den Weg zu einem
humanitären Zweck Zwerg schicken das
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben wir
Gott sei Dank verhindert und auch im
Bereich der Menschenrechte ist diese
Regierung leider auf dem Weg ein Zwerg
zu werden große Worte von Frau baerbock
zu Menschenrechten und Freiheiten China
Kritik am Ausverkauf deutscher
Infrastruktur und dann einknicken und
nur eine kleine Protokoll Notiz beim
china-einstieg in Hamburger Hafen das
ist kein Rückgrat gegenüber dem
Kanzleramt gleiches gilt für die
zutiefst gerückte FIFA Fußball-WM in
Katar statt für die Menschenrechte dort
einzutreten ist von Vizekanzler Habeck
und seiner Verbeugung vor dem ihr dem in
der Innenministerin mit ihrer
unverantwortlichen Wiedergabe der
propaganda-linie Katars bis zur
indifferenten Haltung des Bundeskanzlers
verdammt viel Opportunismus zu sehen
angesichts der Lage und der Blockade
selbst von simplen Armbinden durch FIFA
connection ist es ein Zeichen von
rückgratlosigkeit das Frau Feser sich
heute nicht hier der Debatte stellt
sondern nach Katara ist wir können nur
hoffen dass diese Verzwergung der
deutschen Haltung die unseren Interessen
schadet bald aufhört dass jedenfalls
fordern wir mit Nachdruck
vielen dank Michael Brandt wirft der
Regierung Opportunismus vor und
hatte noch mal Glück dass ihm das
Mikrofon nicht abgestellt wurde
Bundestagsvizepräsident Wolfgang Kubicki
hat mehrmals auf die Zeit verwiesen
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktion lieber Michael
Brandt nach 16 Jahren werden endlich
Menschenrechte in das Zentrum deutscher
Außenpolitik gesetzt nach 16 Jahren
bildet sich Menschenrechtspolitik und
humanitäre Hilfe so stark in einem
Haushaltsplan ab wie noch nie
ja
sie können da ruhig sie können da ruhig
reinrufen ich bin überzeugt wenn sie nur
halb so engagiert ihre evp-freunde
anrufen würden in Europa die sie hier
reinrufen wie sie hier pöbeln dann
könnten sie wirklich etwas für
Menschenrechte erreichen ihre
evp-freunde die in Serbien die EuroPride
verboten haben oder ihre ehemaligen
evp-freunde aus Ungarn wo sie sicher
auch letzte Sitzungswoche beim
rechtsstaatsmechanismus enthalten haben
die sich leidenschaftlich gerne mit dem
polarisieren im Iran treffen stattdessen
pöbeln sie hier gegen die
Außenministerin die eine Sondersitzung
des un- Menschenrechtsrates gegen die
Müllers im Iran durchgesetzt hat sparen
Sie sich Ihre Fass so lange ihre
Europapartei EVP ein Hindernis für
menschenrechtsgeleiterte Außenpolitik
ist
die gute Nachricht ist aber ihre Freunde
von der EVP werden viel Spaß noch mit
dem Europarat als obersten Hüter der
Menschenrechte haben der hat zum
Beispiel gegen ihre
schwesterpartei-regierungen Serbien
durchgesetzt dass dort die EuroPride
trotz Verbot stattfinden konnte
Deutschland wird den Europarat
substanziell stärken die Kompensation
des Ausfalls russischer
Mitgliedsbeiträge und zwei Millionen
obendrauf für den Aktionsplan Ukraine
2,7 Milliarden für die humanitäre Hilfe
ein anwuchs des menschenrechtsetats um
13,3 Millionen und viele kleine wichtige
Projekte von denen ich Einzel
rausstellen möchte denn dieser Haushalt
meine Damen und Herren 2023 er ist auch
für diejenigen da die 2014 den grauen
Folgen
des islamischen Staates ausgesetzt waren
deshalb stärken wir jetzt auch das
Institut für Psychotherapie und
Psychotraumatologie an der Universität
Druck unter Leitung vom großartigen Jan
illhan kisselern das ist
Menschenrechtsarbeit die in ihrer
Substanz unbezahlbar ist danke schön
[Applaus]
ich rede dann ist die Kollegin der ihr
Türke Nachbauer SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und andere hinter der
nüchternen Bezeichnung Einzelplan 05
hinter der Auflistung von ganz vielen
vielen Zahlen steckt der Maßstab mit und
an dem wir uns selber an unserer
Verlässlichkeit unter anderem in der
humanitären Hilfe auf der
internationalen Bühne messen und was
soll ich sagen es ist gut zu wissen
deutschland ist und bleibt verlässlich
danke danke dafür ans AA und an das BMZ
unter anderem liebe Kollegin und
Kollegen ihnen ist wirklich was
wichtiges gelungen sie haben die ein
Teil der wichtigen Antworten auf die
Bekämpfung der zahlreichen Krisen
gefunden und ich vernehme mit Irritation
das ist auch hier Stimmen gibt die
unseren Einsatz in humanitärer Hilfe und
unseren Engagement die Stabilität in der
Welt kleinreden wollen nein es ist nicht
klein zu reden hier ist wirklich was
Großes gelungen nochmals Danke dafür
denn hier ist unsere Solidarität gefragt
wenn die Ukraine völkerrechtswidrig
angegriffen wird dann stehen wir Ihnen
natürlich auch mit humanitärer Hilfe zur
Seite und helfen dabei die unmittelbaren
Auswirkungen des angriffskriegs zu
lindern wenn die russische Föderationen
der Ukraine Kriegsverbrechen begeht und
Menschenrechte mit Füßen tritt dann
unterstützen wir Sie selbstverständlich
dabei Menschenrechts Situation dabei zu
unterstützen die diese Verbrechen
dokumentieren und dabei helfen dass
diese Verbrechen auch bald hoffentlich
geahndet werden als überzeugte
Europäerinnen und Mitglied des
Europarats freue ich mich natürlich
besonders dass diese wichtige
Institution der Kollege Lux sagte ist
die über unsere fundamentalen Werte wie
Menschenrechte Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
demokratiew macht nach dem Ausschuss
Russlands zusätzlich gestützt wird wenn
der menschengemachte Klimawandel dazu
führt das ganze Regionen im globalen
Süden von dürerheim gesucht werden wenn
er kann nicht mehr zu bestellen sind
wenn ganze Landstriche nicht mehr
bewohnbar sind dann stehen wir
selbstverständlich diesen Ländern als
zweitgrößter Geber zur Seite bei den
Mitteln für Frieden und Stabilität ist
im Vergleich zum Regierungsentwurf von
aufwuchs von rund einer Milliarde Euro
zu verzeichnen 4,4 Milliarden Euro in
Frieden Stabilität und Wahrung der
Menschenrechte das ist ein klares Signal
das ist ganz klares Bekenntnis das gilt
das jetzt in Krisenprävention und
Frieden investiert wird ist am Ende
nämlich gespartes Geld während ich jetzt
von dem Einsatz für Menschenrechte Rede
spielt gleichzeitig unseren nationalen
Mannschaft ihr erstes Spiel gerade in
Katar in einer Großveranstaltung bei der
Vergabe sich die FIFA mit allem anderen
als mit Ruhm bekleckert hat diese FIFA
hat mit der Vergabe
genommen dass Menschenrechte zum
Verkaufsobjekt im Schlussverkauf
degradiert worden sind das werden und
dürfen wir nicht hinnehmen Sport ist
politisch wer etwas anderes behauptet
handelt fahrlässig etwas das auf Regeln
und gegenseitige Respekt gründet ist
selbstverständlich politisch der Sport
bringt Menschen und Völker zusammen ohne
die Aufmerksamkeit und Unterstützung auf
Wirtschaft Gesellschaft und Politik
kann der Fußball nicht leben Sport
findet nicht in einem Vakuum statt der
Wettbewerb um Tore Titel Rekorde kann
nicht frei vom Politik geschehen
die FIFA und die anderen großen Verbände
haben dafür gesorgt dass der Zauber der
Fußball-WM und die großartigen
Leistungen unserer Spieler gerade
vollkommen ins Abseits gepfiffen werden
lassen Sie uns das bitte anders machen
lassen Sie uns mit unserem Einsatz für
Menschenrechte verkrustete Strukturen
aufbrechen und neue Maßstäbe setzen
unsere Maßstäbe an die euro24 sind klar
definiert
fußballgroßereignisse machen dann erst
wieder Spaß wenn Respekt Fairness
Transparenz und Nachhaltigkeit die
Sportlerinnen bei ihrem Sprint zum Tor
flankieren wer am Ende die WM gewinnen
wird das ist noch nicht klar was
allerdings jetzt schon klar ist die FIFA
hat die WM jetzt schon verloren danke
[Applaus]
nach Bauer
ich darf darauf hinweisen dass es kein
politisches Emblem ist auch wenn es so
verstanden werden kann sondern es ist
offiziell Emblem der
Fußballnationalmannschaft die in Katar
jetzt gerade spielt und ich finde
verrückt nach Bauer sie haben das Herz
am rechten Fleck
übrigens steht ist Deutschland Japan
noch 0:0 ähm falls das ist sie auch
interessiert und damit kommen wir zum
nächsten Redner Michael Georg Link der
europapolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion
danke Herr Präsident dem kann ich mich
nur von ganz anschließen liebe Kollegin
es war liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eigentlich immer ganz guter Brauch dass
wir in der Haushaltsdebatte zum
ansatzplan 5 auch so eine Runde Europa
drehen und zwar nicht nur eine Runde
Europa sondern eben die aktuellen
Probleme ansprechen da glaube ich genau
Christian Petry kommt anschließend
lieber Christian ich wollte gerade sagen
wir beginnen jetzt diese Runde
so ist es genau aber es ist auch
dringend dass wir das tun denn in der
Tat wir hatten letzte Woche vorletzt in
der letzten Sitzungswoche Deutschland
Parlamentarische Versammlung ist in der
Tat in deutsch-französischen Verhältnis
was er für die EU so unglaublich wichtig
ist vieles zu diskutieren vieles was
auch ja und Fraktionen da ist was so
empfunden wird und deshalb
vorausministerin ich bin in
außerordentlich dankbar dass sie sich
dort bei der Versammlung sehr sehr viel
Zeit genommen haben das zu diskutieren
sich auch kritischen Fragen zu stellen
davon lebt dieses Verhältnis und ihr
Besuch letzte Woche in Frankreich die
Zeit die Energie und überhaupt das
Herzblut dass sie in diese
deutsch-französische Verhältnis
investieren ist unglaublich wichtig
auch gut ja auch gut auch wirklich gut
und wichtig wir haben es gehört die
klare Ankündigung des Kanzlers Richtung
FKS Richtung deutsch-französische
rüstungskooperation für Europa ist das
absolut entscheidend wir brauchen diese
rüstungskooperation dringend wenn die EU
tatsächlich ihre Möglichkeiten erfüllen
will die wir haben und die auch unsere
Partner gerade jenseits des Atlantiks
die im transatanischen Bereich von uns
zu dringend Erwarten gut dass wir da
jetzt hoffentlich wirklich endlich
Vorankommen wir brauchen es auch und wir
brauchen auch vor allem eine europäische
Grundierung unserer nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie und unsere
anstehenden China Strategie sie
europäisch abstimmen und transatlantisch
Erden das sollten wir mit beiden dieser
Strategien tun das ist außerordentlich
wichtig es sind regierungsstrategien ja
aber wir verfolgen sie von Parlament
sehr genau und wir ermuntern die
Bundesregierung das auch wirklich gerade
erneut ich sage es noch einmal
europäisch abzustimmen und
transatlantisch zu erden
wir brauchen drüber hinaus gerade im
Haushaltsbereich wenn wir speziell auch
EU-Haushalt denken wir brauchen bei den
großen Herausforderungen vor denen wir
stehen dürfen wir nicht wieder sozusagen
in der alten Reflexe kommen dann wenn
mehr Geld gebraucht wird dann sozusagen
den einfachsten Weg zu gehen über
gesamtschuldnerische Haftung zu
versuchen Dinge zu machen das wäre
grundfrei falsch wir tun Europa mit
gesamtschuldnerischen Modellen keinen
gefallen deshalb begrüßen wir durchaus
und da unterstützen wir massiv natürlich
den Bundesfinanzminister bei seinem
herangehen daran dass wir auch neue
Eigenmittel so wie sie diskutiert werden
in der EU dass wir sie eben nicht im
Bereich der gesamtschuldnerischen
Haftung machen sondern dort wo es
vernünftigerweise auch mögliche
Mehrheiten gibt die tatsächlich dann die
EU besser finanziell ausstatten würden
und dazu gehört meine Damen und Herren
vor allem dass wir jetzt sehr genau
hinschauen dann hier Ungarn die
Entscheidung steht unmittelbar an sie
steht bevor ob die 7,5 Milliarden
ausgezahlt werden und wir ermuntern Sie
als Bundesregierung aber vor allem auch
den Rat risik-kommission den
Bundestagsbeschluss ernst zu nehmen den
wir haben dass wir gesagt haben wir
wollen das genau hingeschaut wird und
nicht wieder Orban davon kommt und das
Geld bekommt ohne tatsächlich Reformen
zu machen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege link
bevor der Kollege Dr Geran war yabey das
Wortteil von der SPD teile ich mit dass
die deutschen Nationalmannschaft 1:0 für
Deutschland
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Präsident meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren bereits als
Kind träumte alessani saydo davon dr zu
werden
aufgewachsen ist er in Benin eines der
ganzen Länder der Welt
er sagte einmal
meine Eltern hatten nicht die
finanzielle Mittel um die Ausbildung zu
unterstützen
heute
ist Dr seydu promovierte
Agrarwissenschaftler mit Auszeichnung
wie hat der das geschafft
ein dad-stipendium unterstütze ihm bei
seiner Forschungs- und nachhaltige
Landwirtschaft und Tierhaltung
das ist für Benin besonders bedeutend
denn das Land kämpft mit schweren Folgen
des Klimawandels
fakt ist die internationale
Bildungspolitik ist feste Bestandteil
deutscher Außenpolitik das ist Angesicht
multiple Krisen wichtige denn je
investieren wir in Bildung investieren
wir in Frieden Freiheit
Gleichberechtigung und Wohlstand auch
das bedeutet
Zeitenwende für mich
ob aus Benin Senegal oder Halle an der
Saale individuelle Potenziale müssen wir
überall fordern und den Anstieg durch
Bildung ermöglichen
eine Rolle spielen dabei unsere mittlere
Organisation
und das Gehörte Institut Ihr wertvolles
Engagement im Ausland fördert politische
und soziale Teilhaber aber das geht nur
mit einem langfristig planbare stabiler
Finanzierung und genau dafür haben wir
gekämpft mit Erfolg denn die
ursprüngliche geplanten Kürzungen
konnten wir abwenden
der Etat ist Auswärtigen Amts liegt im
Jahr 2023 mit etwa 7,4 Milliarden Euro
höher als je zuvor international ist
wenn Programme fordern wir zusätzlich
mit 38 Millionen Euro und stärken damit
internationale Studierende und
forschernde mit insgesamt 310 Millionen
Euro
sie sehen wenn es um den Haushalt geht
jonglieren wir nicht bezahlen wir nehmen
die Zukunft der Menschen in unserer Hand
[Applaus]
der Schwerpunkt unseres Etat liegt auf
der humanitäre Hilfe deutschland ist
weltweit des zweitgrößte Welt gibt
Geldgeber und konnte damit seiner
internationale Verantwortung nach da
sind die Mittel die verfolgte Menschen
schützen gewähren da sind die Mittel die
die Wissenschaft durch gegenseitige
lernen voranbringen da sind die Mittel
die Lebensbedingungen verbessern und
globale Chancen Gerechtigkeit herstellen
damit Menschen wie dr seydu ihre Träume
verwirklichen können
mit diesen Ergebnissen möchte dr seydu
übrigens
später
politische
einzelentadungen
Entscheidungsträger in seinem Land
beraten um die Lebensverhältnisse vor
Ort zu verbessern dazu trägt der
vorliegende Haushalt wesentlich dass du
bei und ich finde der Ampel hat
geliefert und das ist gut so danke schön
[Applaus]
noch mal auch den Beitrag Deutschland zu
humanitären Hilfe erwähnt auch
bundesaußenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock
hat diesen Jahr in ihrer Rede besonders
gewürdigt und verteidigt
spricht nun für die Unionsfraktion
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Frau Ministerin sie haben sich bisher
für eine Fortsetzung des Einsatzes in
Mali engagiert und seit gestern ist es
Ende der Beteiligung am minusma
beschlossene Sache da würde mich
natürlich schon interessieren warum
gerade jetzt diese Entscheidung viel und
warum dann erst der Abzug Mitte 2024
kommt aktuell kann dieser Einsatz nur
eingeschränkt durchgeführt werden ist
die Bundesregierung nun überzeugt dass
die Rahmenbedingungen kurzfristig wieder
so hergestellt werden können dass die
Mission wie vorgesehen durchgeführt
werden kann zum Beispiel
drohnenaufklärung wenn das so ist dann
würde mich die genaue Begründung für den
Ausstieg interessieren vor allem wenn
sie Frau Ministerin vorher hier an
dieser Stelle sagten dass UN-Missionen
ein zentraler Bestandteil unserer
Außenpolitik unserer Friedenspolitik
bleiben
wenn die Rahmenbedingungen aber nicht
wieder hergestellt werden können dann
stellt sie natürlich die Frage was macht
die Bundeswehr eigentlich in der
verbleibenden Zeit bis 2024 noch dort
das liest sich leider alles mehr als
Fahrer Kompromiss und pastapolitik des
Kanzlers und nicht als die dringend
benötigte Strategie für die
Sicherheitszone
und es steigert nicht ichkeit und das
Vertrauen in Deutschland das Vertrauen
in unser Land das an vielen Stellen
leidet in Osteuropa ganz besonders
wir nehmen alle wahr was in der Ukraine
jeden Tag passiert Energie und
Wärmeversorgung wurde durch die
russischen Kriegsverbrecher weitgehend
zerstört mit katastrophalen Folgen für
die Bevölkerung es finden an den
Frontlinien brutalste Schlachten statt
mit extrem hohen Opferzahlen und wir
machen hier in unserer Gemächlichkeit
weiter es war jetzt die Chance dass
ukrainische Momentum zu nutzen mit
Unterstützung mit Waffensystemen wie dem
Leopard mit denen Schritt für Schritt
auch eine technische Überlegenheit
erreicht werden kann diese Chance wurde
leider schon vor Monaten verpasst und
der Kanzler stellt sich hier heute
morgen hin und sagt wir liefern das was
gebraucht wird meine Damen und Herren
das ist wirklich an den Haaren
herbeigezogen es ist schwierig und man
wird wirklich zornig wenn man sich das
immer und immer wieder anhören muss und
den Überlebenskampf der Ukraine jeden
Tag verfolgt es ist unfassbar dass wir
Herr bitzen liefern und sich niemand in
dieser Regierung um die
Ersatzteilversorgung Gedanken gemacht
hat es ist unfassbar dass bei den 60
nichteinsatzbereiten Haubitzen niemand
einen Finger rührt mit denen könnten wir
vielleicht noch weiter unterstützen um
meine Damen und Herren mit Blick auf die
kaufpanzer es ist nun mittlerweile
wirklich jede Ausrede die sich das
Kanzleramt ausgedacht hat widerlegt auch
durch Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus den
ampelfraktionen handeln sie durch
endlich und starten Sie eine europäische
rüstungsinitiative die eine
kontinuierliche Belieferung der Ukraine
mit Waffen und Munition garantiert und
fangen Sie mit den Dingen an die
unkompliziert auf den Weg gebracht
werden Marder Leopard haben wir vielfach
erwähnt handelt sie nach den Zielen
die sie als Regierung selber formuliert
haben Russland darf diesen brutalen
Angriffskrieg nicht gewinnen wenn wir
dementsprechend handeln dann würde auch
Vertrauen und Glaubwürdigkeit in unser
Land zurückkehren denn Wort und Tat
fallen oft auseinander auch wenn wir zum
Beispiel Afrikaner bei afrikanischen
Staaten dafür werden wollen sich nicht
zu abhängig von China zu machen und
gleichzeitig China bei uns in wichtige
Infrastruktur einsteigt
Glaubwürdigkeit leidet auch in der
klima-außenpolitik wenn wir anderen
vorschreiben wie sie CO2 einsparen
sollen aber gleichzeitig bei uns der
Ausstoß massiv steigt weil wir aus
ideologischer Verblendung
Kohlekraftwerke hochfahren statt
vorhandene Kernkraftwerke für eine kurze
Übergangszeit weiterlaufen zu lassen und
meine Damen und Herren
Wort und Tat die Menschen im Iran warten
auf kraftvolle Zeichen der Unterstützung
und da muss dann mehr kommen Frau
Ministerin als nur Sanktionen zu
überprüfen das islamische Zentrum in
Hamburg ist immer noch nicht geschlossen
revolutionsgarten immer noch nicht auf
das Aktionsliste es hilft nicht wenn man
hier beschreibt was nicht geht es sind
Taten gefragt und gefordert
meine Damen und Herren wir leben in
fordernden Zeiten Freiheit Demokratie
ist weltweit unter Druck und die müssen
wir entgegentreten auch durch intensive
zivilgesellschaftliche Vernetzung das
haben sie auch im Koalitionsvertrag
niedergelegt wo es heißt lieber
internationale Kooperation wichtiger und
daher Räumen wie er einen hohen
Stellenwert ein dieser Stellenwert wurde
im Haushaltsentwurf nicht deutlich bei
der auswärtigen Kultur- und
Bildungspolitik war das ein Desaster und
ich bin froh dass unsere Forderungen
auch aufgenommen wurden aber es ist
wahrlich kein Grund zur Jubel kein Grund
zum Jubel wenn man in der
Bereinigungssitzung das Schlimmste
verhindert
die
die steigenden Energiepreise
Energiepreise Immobilienpreise
Personalkosten
bedeuten am Schluss dass wir unsere
Aktivitäten reduzieren müssen wenn man
nur konstant bleiben können wir nicht
das leisten was wir leisten wollen und
unsere Mittler brauchen
Planungssicherheit und nicht jedes Jahr
eine Zitterpartie meine Damen und Herren
diese Regierung braucht eine seitenwende
hin zu einer konsistenten Politik wir
brauchen nicht
unterschiedliche Signale die diese
Regierung immer in unterschiedliche
Richtung aussendet wir brauchen
konsistente Politik und dann werden wir
auch wieder als verlässlicher Partner
angesehen nicht nur schöne Worte sondern
auch beherztes Handeln ist gefragt
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank damit kommen wir zum letzten
Redner zum Einzelplan 5 des Auswärtigen
Amts das ist Christian Petry ja wurde ja
schon angesprochen als europapolitischer
Sprecher der
Sozialdemokraten hier im Deutschen
Bundestag
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren wir haben es heute
schon mehrfach diskutiert und gesagt
Europa in Europa ist Krieg deshalb
brauchen wir eine europäische Politik
der Geschlossenheit Michael Link ich bin
wirklich froh dass du auch etwas zu
Europa gesagt hast in dieser Debatte
denn es ist sehr bedeutend wir brauchen
die Geschlossenheit die Geschlossenheit
die wir gezeigt haben in dieser Krise
die muss fortgeführt werden diese
Bundesregierung steht dafür diese
Geschlossenheit diese Geschlossenheit
wurde gezeigt in militärischem Handeln
in finanzieller Unterstützung in
gesellschaftlicher Unterstützung in
humanitäre Unterstützung in der Politik
allgemein das ist eine starke Leistung
die diese Bundesregierung in Europa mit
unseren Partnern gestaltet hat
und im Haushalt wurde dazu auch deutlich
Dargel nachgelegt das ist gesagt worden
die Stärkung der internationalen
Organisationen OSZE muss genannt werden
aber auch der europaweit hier haben wir
die Lücke geschlossen das war eine große
Leistung danke an dieses Parlament der
Europarat mit dem Europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte in dem
alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger Europas ihre
Rechte einklagen können selbst wenn sie
es in ihrem Land nicht können hier haben
wir Vorreiter gespielt haben die Lücke
geschlossen und es ist ausfinanziert im
Haushalt herzlichen Dank dafür
diesem Zusammenhang würde ich mich sehr
freuen wenn wir dort in Kürze den
Beschluss fassen können dass das Kosovo
aufgenommen wird das wäre wirklich eine
positive Maßnahme das unterstützen wir
Deutschland ist im Fokus der
Europapolitik wer hätte denn vor zwei
Jahren gedacht wenn wir in Brüssel
aufgetaucht werden hat gesagt
Deutschland muss mehr militärische
Verantwortung übernehmen was wären da
los gewesen der hat die meisten gesagt
haben auch was mit was kommt der denn
jetzt so und jetzt jetzt ist es so und
das tun wir auch und das tun wir mit
unserem Partnern gemeinsam in der
deutsch-französischen Zusammenarbeit im
deutsch-französischen Parlament
zugegebenermaßen da sind jetzt ein paar
mehr drin die überhaupt keine Lust auf
diese deutsch-französische
Zusammenarbeit haben ich weiß ja gar
nicht was sie da wollen außer Störfeuer
das ist schade ich danke aber allen ich
danke aber allen zum Beispiel Andreas
Jung der hier mit in der Gründung dieser
Versammlung stark mitgearbeitet hat das
ist ein Werk das wir weiterentwickeln
müssen wo wir unsere Partnerschaft in
Europa positiv wirken lassen und ich bin
froh dass es viele Kolleginnen und
Kollegen gibt die hier sehr engagiert
mitarbeiten
[Applaus]
es gilt dass wir in Europa aufpassen
aufpassen über Tendenzen die sich
entwickeln und hier schaue ich unsere
konservativen Freunde an wie wir
Demokraten müssen das Bollwerk gegen
Rechts sein
wenn in Polen die Justiz und die Medien
unter Druck stehen in Ungarn ist es
mehrfach genannt worden trotzdem aber
auf dieser Seite des Hauses intensive
Kontakte und Unterstützung laufen dann
muss man sich hinterfragen tut das dem
demokratischen Gedanken wirklich gut
hier fordere ich Sie auf bitte überlegen
Sie Ihre Strategie ihre Strategie wir
müssen diese rechtstendenzen in Europa
vor allem die Rechtsradikalen Tendenzen
die meine ich damit verhindern Italien
lässt grüßen Italien ist wissen was hat
denn Herr Weber mit Herrn pauluskuni
gemacht was ist denn jetzt passiert wen
haben wir denn da
Schweden auch hier ist die konservative
Partei dabei sich mit rechts mit ganz
rechts zu verbinden und hier vorder ist
die Aufsicht abzugrenzen in Europa das
ist eine Aufgabe der Demokraten das
Bollwerk gegen Rechts in Europa zu
bilden
also Herr Nachtwächter ich brauche von
ihnen keiner ich brauche von ihnen keine
Belehrung über Demokratie Demokrat
europa braucht eine Stärkung europa
braucht eine Stärkung der Perspektive
eine Stärkung der Perspektive für die
Menschen die zu Öl zu der Europäischen
Union kommen wollen beispielsweise im
Balkan oder auch in den Ländern Ukraine
Moldau und Georgien und Herr Link ich
bin fast am Ende mit der Finanzierung
der Eigenmittel da haben wir
unterschiedliche Auffassungen
solidarische Finanzierung können
Instrumente zur Finanzierung sein da
werden wir drüber reden gestalten wir
den Weg zu Europa nachhaltig
sozialverträglich in der Transformation
ins digitale Zeitalter
arbeiten wir gemeinsam gegen die
Brandstifter von rechts damit wir eine
gute Zukunft in Europa haben das wird
ein schwieriger Weg aber wir werden ihn
gestalten vielen Dank Glückauf
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Petri ich
erlaube mir Hinweis dass Herr
Kleinwächter Kleinwächter und nicht
Nachtwächter heißen ich
[Gelächter]
dringend darum bitten würde dass wir mit
Namen keine verwalterung betreiben das
ist einfach unangenehm so damit schließe
ich dir
schließlich Aussprache wir kommen zur
Abstimmung über den Einzelplan